en marge de la fête internet qui a
démarré hier en france je vous propose
de découvrir
l'inventeur d'internet l'homme et
américains c'est en 1974 avec l'un de
ses amis qui l'a mise au point l'
architecture qui permettrait de faire
entrer dans chacun des foyers américains
le réseau pari réussi puisque
aujourd'hui un tiers des adultes aux
états unis sont connectés grâce au génie
de winton certes c'est son nom véritable
humaniste que nous présente
maryse burgot il roule en jaguar ne sort
jamais sans son chapeau et son costume
trois pièces jamais non plus sans une
petite valise
cet homme à l'élégance tout britannique
est américain et s'il n'a pas le look
habituel des fondus d'informatique il
n'en est pas moins considéré comme
l'inventeur de l'internet
on ne s'étonnera donc pas de ce qu'il
transporte dans sa petite valise
qu'est-ce que j'ai là dedans en fait
c'est un ordinateur d'état de file des
convertisseurs et des papiers vinton
cerf est ainsi inséparable de son
ordinateur portable qu'il rebranche dès
qu'il rentre à la maison
vinton cerf ou l'histoire d'un inventeur
heureux car c'est un peu grâce afin
trouve un et grâce à l'internet que son
époux a autrefois sourde entend
aujourd'hui les mots de son mari c'est
en effet en cherchant sur l'internet
cette immense banque d'informations
qu'elle a appris il ya quelques années
qu'elle pouvait être soigné et enterré
je suis allé sur l'internet et j'ai
trouvé beaucoup de renseignements sur la
technique des implants et en quelques
semaines j'étais capable de programmer
une date d'opération la possibilité pour
beaucoup de gens de mettre des
informations dans une sorte de pot
commun c'est à dire sur le net est un
moyen très très puissant et faire se
rencontrer leurs idées et leurs maîtres
vinton cerf fait aujourd'hui vice
président de m6 un numéro deux américain
de la téléphonie un véritable cerveau
qui impressionne son staff d'ingénieurs
dans les années 60 ce sont les
militaires américains qui ont inventé
les prémices de l'internet maison 74
vinton cerf fait l'un de ses amis
imagine l architecture finale qui relie
aujourd'hui via des ordinateurs des
millions de particuliers dans le monde
c'est cette communication de groupe
ce partage qui rend l'internet sismique
c'est en cela que cette technologie est
révolutionnaire vinton cerf est aussi un
grand connaisseur de vins de bordeaux
une passion qui lui vient de france la
france où il a créé une association pour
promouvoir l'internet et faire que notre
pays apprécie autant l'informatique que
le vin